expansion across the valley is really
nothing new in downtown Las Vegas the
new Civic Plaza is on the way along with
more businesses retail and the Arts but
all of these new developments also mean
more people living in that area Madison
Kimbrough spoke to the city today to get
the scoop on some possible new arrivals
Madison joins us live near the Smith
Center with more
now the Smith Center in Symphony Park
are popular places from shows to special
events as you can see but if you live
here this pocket of Las Vegas needs two
things more parking and a grocery store
and city leaders are working to get both
we do live in a food desert and there's
very few options for people within the
downtown core to have access to a
grocery store the downtown core near
Symphony Park is rich in the Arts and
restaurants but challenged when it comes
to Everyday Necessities Brittany
Fitzpatrick is a local and agrees a
grocery store is a must we desperately
need one because we walk downtown to do
to eat a lot we do everything downtown
besides grocery shopping at Wednesday's
city council meeting a proposed
development agreement will be discussed
city leaders say this empty lot is
primed for high-end condos a grocery
store and expanded parking for residents
and visitors especially as a downtown
and arts district is continuing to grow
so much would be great if there was some
sort of better parking option councilman
Brian Knutson of Ward 1 says it's vital
the city keeps up with the demand the
downtown's been getting busier and
busier and busier and better and more
fun and exciting which means parking
becomes more of a challenge and so the
city's put a concerted effort into
making parking more accessible in the
downtown core and it's already happening
a new parking garage is in the works for
the Arts District and another in the
nearby Medical District I fully expect a
parking garage in the Medical District
in the next couple of months
the idea for this area is mixed use and
the potential condo and grocery store
would be located on Grand Central
Parkway that's adjacent to these
apartments now this proposal will be
discussed at tomorrow's city council
meeting reporting live in Downtown
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now